justin herbert who got an unexpected
start in week two against the chiefs is
getting an expected start
in week three against the carolina
panthers here's his head coach anthony
lynn addressing the ascension of justin
herbert on wednesday
justin herbert was started quarterback
i'm looking forward to seeing him play
with a week of preparation knowing that
he's going to be the starter
uh what were some positives that you
took from the game uh that he had
against kansas city
i'll tell you just uh
his his pores he didn't panic you know
uh he made some
really nice throws in that game and
moved around showed that he can extend
plays
you know uh he did some good things in
that game but uh he was not fully
prepared because he didn't take all the
reps uh in practice and you know i've
learned over the years as a as a young
coach you know i remember coach shanahan
telling me one time you know don't don't
tell me how many times you told them
tell me how many times you put them
through it and so that was some
situation we just did not put him
through last week and i thought he
handled those situations well
much as well extremely well and i
understand there's a psychology involved
here you don't want the kid getting a
big head but i don't think it would
affect him i i think some praise is in
order for what we saw from justin
herbert last week
you consider what he can do
against a lesser team
with a full week to prepare with the
coaching staff able to prepare based
upon what he does well and what he
doesn't do well right i don't know that
there's much he doesn't do well this is
a hell of an opportunity for justin
herbert to make it clear that even when
tyrod taylor is healthy justin herbert
is the guy yeah no doubt i i do think
this is a an opportunity for him against
a panthers defense that we know has
given up a lot of plays where he could
probably go in there this week and
establish himself for the starter for
the rest of the year you know being the
number six pick of the draft uh showing
what he showed last week you put another
solid performance together you know you
have a defense and you start to feel
like hey i think we can trust this guy
you know not only the reps and the
things like that putting them through
all the things you need to do hey just
the fact that when you're in the starter
the offensive coordinator and the head
coach start to beat little things into
your brain too about hey when it's
second to you know no turnovers no
throwing the ball across your body just
all those type of things that you you
need to hear during the week when you're
a young quarterback just uh you know so
when it does happen and all of a sudden
you're running out to the left you can
hear like anthony lynn's voice in your
head going don't throw it across your
body and i'm telling you that's the crap
that happens to you as a quarterback you
literally hear that and then you go oh
let me throw it out of bounds and and
that'll go a long way for him but as we
both saw and i think we both sat there
on sunday and i know we're not together
anymore but i see you on this big screen
and see your reactions i mean there was
eye-popping plays from justin herbert
eye-popping and you watched back the
game as did i and the the watching it
back confirmed that too so um i i think
they got a chance to put up some points
in some yards and i'm excited to see
what erberg does i was blown away by
everything about justin herbert's game
his throwing his running his power his
awareness his hustle and and
i was
i was
doing a little research yesterday i was
trying to find a clip of that play that
we've talked about where austin eckler
was running the ball and herbert
sprinted to the area just in case
something would happen so i googled
justin herbert hustle just as i wanted
to find that clip and i wanted to embed
it in the story that i had and i found a
clip of a play from him at oregon where
there was a turnover and it was the
equivalent of the ben roethlisberger
play from the playoffs in 2005 where
roethlisberger saved the day cardboard
but this time but this time the day was
saved by justin herbert running the
entire length of the field choosing an
angle sprinting to the spot and keeping
the defender out of the end zone so uh
it it i mean the guy is a football
player he is that's what we're looking
for
and uh he's a football player who
happens to play quarterback and he's
going to get to play on sunday for the
chargers let me ask you this yeah how
much can the panthers glean from last
week's film to help them
prepare for what's coming i think that
yeah there's not going to be a ton
they'll be able to just look at okay
here's some of the core plays of what
the chargers do on offense we've seen
this through the first two weeks and all
that
but i think what
you know what it is going to be certain
things about the game that they're not
going to be ready for or probably some
plays that they did not expect you know
but the one thing is they know how
athletic he is so they're gonna have to
get into all right we gotta talk about
containing them doing things like that
but the the thing where i think they'll
have the advantage is
you know i would imagine with a guy that
can play that way and move that way and
then make the power throws that we just
saw last week you know those are the
guys that go play action pass protect it
up let him get some separation from the
line of scrimmage and let two guys work
downfield let mike williams and keenan
allen do some intricate route running
and you let him sit back there and throw
them 20 in 25 yard strikes those are the
things that aren't on the film a lot
with the chargers to where
yes this week the panthers i think would
have a good chance of seeing that if i
was the office coordinator for the
chargers those are the type of plays i
would certainly want to see more of
because it makes the game simple for a
young quarterback right hey one receiver
two receiver
check down run that's all you got to do
and then if it's not there throw it away
because we got a good defense and we'll
punt it out and we'll try to do it again
the next series and uh that's where
you know i think they can make this work
with herbert as a quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports